so picture this I'm shooting a video and
I hear a knock at my door
and I turn around go to the door and
then I see a pizza box that is sitting
like this sideways I didn't order pizza
but I'm also really hungry so if this is
a pizza and it's an accident I'm going
to devour it is this a real Pizza I
don't know are you sure maybe don't open
it what if it's Anthrax well it turns
out it's Pi Day
3.141592654 and so on this right here is
not a pizza it's the first thing that we
are greeted with it's a Call of Duty
skateboard deck like ah this is so
freaking exciting look at this oh man we
gotta get this some duct tape on here
and get this thing out into the streets
so sick not a pizza patch display Banner
underneath
it's actually a banner
and this oh heck yeah and a little place
to put the patch on this is so great I'm
not gonna lie this is better than a
pizza